we tend to reproach ourselves for
staring out of the window you're
supposed to be working or studying
ticking off things on your to-do list it
can seem almost the definition of wasted
time it appears to produce nothing to
serve no purpose
there's no prestige in it and we don't
go around saying I had a great day
the high point was staring out of the
window but maybe in a better society
that's just the sort of thing people
would say to one another the point of
staring out of a window is paradoxically
not to find out what's going on outside
it is rather an exercise in discovering
the contents of our own minds it's easy
to imagine we know what we think what we
feel and what's going on in our heads
but we rarely do entirely there's a huge
amount of what makes us who we are that
circulates unexplored and unused
it's shy and doesn't emerge under the
pressure of direct questioning if we do
it right staring out of the window
offers us a way to listen out for the
quieter suggestions and perspectives of
our inner nature's the philosopher Plato
suggested a metaphor for the mind it's
full of ideas like birds fluttering
around in the aviary of our brains but
in order for the birds to settle Plato
understood that we need periods of calm
staring out of the window offers such an
opportunity the potential of daydreaming
isn't recognized by society's obsessed
with productivity but some of our
greatest insights come when we stop
trying to be purposeful and instead
respect the creative potential of
reverie window daydreaming is a
strategic rebellion against the
excessive demands of the immediate but
ultimately insignificant pressures in
favor of the diffuse but very serious
search for the insights of our deeper
selves
you